bonsoir thomas peut-on retenir de cette
audition aujourd'hui
et bien c'est une audition comme celle
d'hier qui a lieu dans un contexte
évidemment très compliqué pour
l'exécutif ici aux etats-unis anthony
blinken a en quelque sorte endosser la
responsabilité de ce retrait devant le
congrès il a dû donc défendre cette
décision pour le moins controversé
devant les élus américains beaucoup de
critiques ont été exprimées lors de ces
deux auditions notamment évidemment de
la part d'élus républicains alors la
première explication qui était attendue
c'était de savoir sur quels éléments
s'était appuyé le président joe biden
pour prendre cette décision du retrait
des troupes américaines écouté les
explications d'anthony benken
en janvier 2021 les talibans étaient
plus fort militairement que jamais
depuis longtemps septembre si nous
avions le plus faible nombre de soldats
sur place depuis 2001
en conséquence dès sa prise de fonction
le président biden a été confronté à un
choix
mettre fin à la guerre ou engager une
escalade s'il n'avait pas donné suite à
la promesse de son prédécesseur les
attaques contre nos forces et vos alliés
auraient repris et les assauts des
talibans sur les grandes villes afghanes
auraient commencé
mais la question centrale qui a animé
les débats c'est de savoir pourquoi les
autorités américaines n'ont pas anticipé
la progression des taliban là encore
anthony blinken a tenté de se défendre
mais beaucoup de sénateurs notamment ont
souligné le fait que des informations
auraient pu voir aurait dû mener à une
décision voire une stratégie
complètement différente c'est le cas par
exemple du sénateur de floride marco
rubio écouter cet échange entre donc ce
sénateur républicain et le chef de la
diplomatie américaine
nous aurions dû savoir que lorsque nous
avons commencé à baisser notre appui
envers l'armée afghane nous allions voir
le risque d'un effondrement et c'est
aussi tout ce que ces profs des monstres
et donc c'est inquiétant que personne
n'ait vu tout ça et qu'il a été conclu
qu'il n'y avait pas de preuves ou de
raisons de croire qu'il pourrait y avoir
un effondrement rapide
rien de ce que j'ai vu ce que nous avons
vu pouvait laisser suggérer que ce
gouvernement et les forces de sécurité
allait s'effondrer en jour
et vous avez raison nous devons regarder
en arrière sur tout ça parce que nous
avons collectivement investi sur ces
vingt dernières années des sommes
astronomiques dans l'effort de sécurité
le gouvernement
des centaines de milliards de dollars
dans l'équipement les entraînements axés
terreur
et on se base on là dessus encore une
fois nous n'avons pas vu cet
effondrement arrivé en quelques jours
mais c'est important que nous regardions
derrière nous et que nous analysions
tout ça
beaucoup d'autres points ont été abordés
lors de ces deux auditions qui ont été
très dense parmi les points abordés il
ya la difficulté d'établir des liens
diplomatiques avec les talibans en
afghanistan ou encore et bien la place
des femmes justement dans le pays ou
encore le fait que l'afghanistan puisse
à nouveau abriter des organisations
terroristes à l'avenir d'ailleurs on a
appris aujourd'hui que les services de
renseignement américains avaient affirmé
que d'ici un an ou deux ans al qaïda
pourrait de nouveau s'établir en
afghanistan enfin beaucoup de questions
sur les profils justement des afghans
qui ont été évacués du pays ces
dernières semaines notamment ceux qui
sont déjà présents actuellement sur le
sol américain on pourra noter pour finir
que ces deux auditions ont été le
théâtre d'affrontements idéologiques
notamment donc entre les républicains
très critiques contre les agissements de
joe biden et de son gouvernement
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington